Brad Pitt and Angelina Jolie have come  to a temporary custody agreement et can  confirm the former couple made a custody  deal that will last three weeks which  includes temporary and random drug  testing you think the story's gonna have  a happy ending happy endings of stories  magnet a source is familiar with the  temporary agreements hell et Brad's  first visit with the kids will be  monitored to determine whether the actor  will have future unmonitored visits  while the 52 year old actor volunteered  to undergo random and alcohol drug  testing both pitt and Jolie volunteered  to do individual counseling as for how  Jolie is feeling a source close to the  child custody dispute tells ET quote she  is only concerned with the health and  safety of her children the actress filed  for divorce after two years of marriage  with Pitt earlier this month asking for  full physical custody of the pair's six  children  you